bene grazie buonasera marco gai classe
76 sposato tre figli l'imprenditore
imprenditore che
imprenditori di prima generazione che ha
deciso nel 2000 di iniziare la sua
attività di impresa dove dopo un passato
familiare
l'industria e poi ho deciso di fare la
mia strada la mia strada convinto che
coltivare il sogno che stava dentro di
me cioè quello di intraprendere qualche
cosa vedersi realizzare un progetto
un'idea potesse essere qualcosa che per
me poteva fare la differenza e
possibilmente nel futuro potevano fare
anche la differenza per quello che era
il mio il mio territorio e l'ecosistema
diciamo così in cui vivo quindi
impegnato poi nell'attività di
confindustria fino a diventare permetto
di dire orgoglioso presidente dei
giovani imprenditori del piemonte che mi
sento di rappresentare in quanto
presidente e non presidente in quanto li
rappresenta quindi un gioco di parole
che però per me ha molta importanza e
dal significato di come di come
approccio il ruolo che secondo me anche
gli imprenditori che ogni tanto viene
messo un po da parto viene considerato
come quello che non è sempre la persona
migliore da imitare o da guardare invece
per me il ruolo sociale che noi abbiamo
è che tutti noi abbiamo è determinante
stasera volevo parlarvi di cambiamento
giovani responsabilità il futuro
cambiamento come tema centrale perché
del nostro paese ha tanto bisogno di
cambiamento ha tanto bisogno di giovani
che sono il nostro futuro questa sera è
stato detto più di una volta il ruolo
che hanno i giovani e come i giovani
dovrebbero essere leader e ambasciatori
del futuro grazie a quello che hanno che
la loro italianità per me centrale e
responsabilità perché la responsabilità
credo che sia alla base di tutte le
nostre azioni
responsabilmente
dovremo studiare responsabilmente
dovremmo essere padri e madri di
famiglia responsabilmente dobbiamo fare
impresa responsabilmente dobbiamo essere
colleghi collaboratori dipendenti quindi
è un tema a cui credo molto
la difficoltà di questo momento è sempre
quella che ci fa dire è difficile e
allora io volevo riportarvi un piccolo
spezzone se parte di una cosa che
siccome ogni tanto mi da anche la
volontà di pensare in maniera differente
se parte non parto
partito no
c'era un player
va beh nel frattempo continua questo
potrebbe essere un po l'ispirazione che
magari lo aggiorniamo un'altra volta
quindi questa è la dimostrazione di
quello che abbiamo appena fatto eco
insomma
si può fare
doveva essere un po più in linea col
discorso ma ma l'abbiamo recuperato
allora perché perché volevo far vedere
questo spezzone perché ogni tanto quello
che viviamo tutti i giorni ci fa pensare
che è tutto troppo difficile tutto
troppo complicato è tutto troppo in
salita per poterlo percorrere è in
realtà questo spezzone del dancing
frankestein junior che conoscete e con
questo pizzico di follia che è anche
genio un po quello che dovremmo avere
noi come come come come spirito per
partire e per poter fare la differenza
essere promotore del cambiamento con
responsabilità prima di tutto verso i
giovani i giovani sono una
responsabilità noi siamo giovane io mi
ritengo ancora giovane e ritengo che in
passato la mia famiglia ha avuto una
responsabilità ai miei confronti e un po
meno il mio paese in questo momento e
quindi la responsabilità di cambiare
paese per i nostri giovani è
fondamentale
l'orgoglio per me l'orgoglio del
mestiere che faccio come lo faccio e
centrare anche perché parto molto spesso
da una riflessione che diviene dalle
nostre radici
noi siamo un popolo eccezionale un
popolo che ha inventato qualsiasi cosa
voi oggi usate in maniera embrionale e
siamo un popolo di
sì che ha portato l'innovazione in giro
per il mondo e purtroppo troppo spesso è
riuscita a farsela portare via dagli
altri l'ha lasciata andare non godendo
di quella che era la grande capacità
l'azione
l'azione è quello di cui noi siamo
capaci perché siamo capaci di grande e
di grande pensiero e poi siamo capaci di
metterlo in azione in concretezza e
questo riguarda il il cambiamento con
due concetti secondo me molto collegati
che sono l'ecosistema che l'ecosistema
in cui viviamo cioè il nostro paese il
nostro territorio il nostro mondo dove
facciamo impresa e dobbiamo migliorarlo
dobbiamo cambiarlo dobbiamo far sì che
dal non è un paese per giovani può
diventare un paese per giovani ma
soprattutto mi viene a dire che può
diventare un paese dove l'essere
italiani e fare impresa
si inizia a sentire nei bar al posto di
quello che noi sentiamo sempre non si
può andare avanti così questo non si può
fare questo non non riesco a farlo
sempre un sacco di problemi ci la
burocrazia non riesco ma a sentire un
paese dove dire ho realizzato qualcosa
di bello ho conosciuto qualcosa stasera
abbiamo visto delle eccellenze delle
persone che si sono reinventate o
inventate e quindi questo è un orgoglio
e un orgoglio di cui dovremmo discutere
e discutere molto di più convivenza
generazionale
tutti parlano di patto generazionale di
equità generazionale a me piace parlare
di convivenza generazionale in cui padri
e figli nonni e figli lavorano insieme
uno trasmette sapere all'altro e l'altro
con umiltà capisce che anche i modi
molto spesso non lineare che che i
nostri che chi ci insegna utilizza con
noi sono fin di bene e quindi cerca di
capire di prendere in questa convivenza
generazionale si può veramente
condividere
un futuro e la cultura italiana come vi
ho detto prima deve essere la nostra
bandiera perché riusciamo a fare a
realizzare delle cose che diversamente
non sono realizzabili e quindi si parla
di futuro si parla di cambiamento e si
parla con tutti questi strumenti che
abbiamo a disposizione cioè noi stessi
della capacità di lavorare in sinergia
questo è il futuro lavorare in sinergia
lavorare con strategia cioè noi dovremmo
avere il coraggio di pensare a cosa
faremo fra dieci anni e fra 20 anni sia
nelle nostre aziende che fuori la nostra
azienda nella nostra famiglia ma
soprattutto nel nostro paese è questo il
ruolo e dei giovani la responsabilità
dei giovani oggi e impegnarsi e cambiare
le cose essere i veri motori del
cambiamento e in questo modo costruire
il loro futuro perché nel loro futuro
vivere in italia deve essere un
privilegio devono essere contenti andare
all'estero deve essere un'opportunità e
non una necessità stresso questo
concetto perché io ho un bambino che io
chiamo ancora bambino che ha 17 anni e
lui oggi mi sta dicendo che vorrebbe
fare l'università all'estero ma non come
opportunità perché mi dice che qua non
trova gli stimoli e io devo impegnarmi
perché quali stimoli li trovi e sia
orgoglioso mi piace anche molto
attaccato al concetto della cultura di
impresa
l'oman e di umanesimo industriale forse
dovremmo rimettere al centro l'uomo
l'essere umano le persone fanno la
differenza le hanno sempre fatte
ce ne siamo un po perse per la strada
pensando che si poteva fare senza e
bastava essere splendidamente
organizzati ma in realtà noi dobbiamo
essere sì splendidamente organizzati
valorizzando quello che l'essere umano e
la nostra capacità la contaminazione ci
aiuta a fare questo stasera io mi sento
fortemente contaminato e spero che per
tutti sia stata la se stessa sensazione
torno a casa con qualcosa di più di
quando sono arrivato qui e quindi a
parte
la speranza di poter aver contribuito a
questo io ho speso bene il mio tempo
perché domani sicuramente a processo
tutto quello che andrò a fare in una
maniera migliore
tre cose ultime le start up innovative
sono il futuro delle nostre aziende ma
non perché sono bisogna essere start
upper perché fa tendenza o perché come
spesso si dice è figo ma perché sono il
vero centro di ricerca innovazione che
le nostre aziende possono avere possono
sfruttare in cui possono investire e da
cui sicuramente possono avere un ritorno
sia in termini chiaramente economici
perché l'impresa è al centro della start
up ma anche in termini di prospettiva
per il paese
ho quasi finito con gli ultimi tre
concetti che sono il sogno se smettiamo
di sognare credo che smettiamo di vivere
e noi di sognare non dobbiamo smettere e
ci va il coraggio di sognare il coraggio
di intraprendere il coraggio di fare di
portare avanti le proprie le proprie
istanze con ottimismo a me spesso dicono
che sono un ottimista è vero ma io ho
spesso rispondo che ottimista per me è
la persona che sa che ci sono dei
problemi ma sa trovarne le soluzioni
quindi una grande opportunità che
abbiamo quella di migliorare il presente
per costruire il nostro futuro per noi
per i nostri giovani
grazie